hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
early on in book three of his
meditations Marcus Aurelius sets out for
us some insights about pleasure and
Beauty in what we could call an
aesthetic framework that is looking at
things sensing them taking them in and
finding something of value there that a
lot of people are going to miss out on
or even just have an opposite reaction
to and consider
ugly and this is a very interesting
thing that he's pointing out because
typically we look at stoics as being if
not against pleasure at least largely
indifferent to it and Marcus isn't
saying well you should pursue pleasure
as much as you want like some sort of
hedonist but he is willing to say you
know there's a lot of beauty and
pleasure out there waiting for you you
just have to look at at it in the right
way with the right point of view and
he's going to give us some ideas about
what that is so he starts by saying
it's necessary is the Greek term there
this sort of in indefinite verb that
just suggests this is what ought to be
done so we ought to remember and this is
a very interesting term here as well
paraphulation so
Fula chain means to guard to preserve to
hold on to right to keep within us and
then the para sort of accentuates it
right we ought to keep in mind we ought
to have ready to deploy this this
Insight that the as it's being
translated here by Hayes inadvertences
of nature now the Greek is a little bit
more complicated and notice that we've
got the same verb essentially repeated
here so nature is toys
so fuses is nature right and this is the
things that are happening the things
that are arising that are coming into
being through nature right so the
natural world and it's many many
different matters now inadvertences
epigenomena this implies coming after
Epi in this case so the things that come
into being out of things that are coming
into being through nature right the
extra stuff the Surplus the could be
also
things that we typically view as
problematic or bad and it tells us that
each of these has its charm T uhari
right and this is coming from two
different terms
some something that is you know Grace
Joy something that is uh we respond to
and then the T A Certain a a kind of
right so a certain kind of charm and
even attractiveness
right a capacity to attract to Fascinate
us
so this is a very interesting thing to
say how do we put this all together we
should keep in mind that all these
things of nature even in what seems to
be Superfluous going wrong you know
they're imperfections possess their own
charm and attractiveness and he gives us
a whole bunch of examples here many of
which have to do with gustatory Delights
right he says the way loaves of bread
split open on top in the oven the ridges
are just byproducts of the baking and
yet they're pleasing to us think about
an uh you know golden loaf of bread with
that crack and every single one is
slightly different than the other none
of them are perfect but you look at it
and you're like that looks good right
and he says somehow they Rouse our
appetite without us knowing why we not
only have a visual aesthetic reaction to
it we also have a gustatory aesthetic
reaction we're like I want to eat that
piece of bread that looks really good
that loaf of bread right and we can
think of other examples he says how ripe
figs begin to burst now you know if you
live in a place where figs are not all
that common you could think about
a peach or apricot right that is so
close to ripeness or a plum or berries
or you could think of an avocado you
know as it's getting slightly mushy and
beginning to give right bananas great
and other great example you don't want
to eat them when they're green and you
don't want to eat them when they're pure
yellow you want to wait until they start
to get a little bit brown right that
carbohydrates are breaking down into
sugars and they're becoming sweet he
says olives on the point of falling from
the tree right and we can think of all
sorts of other things raspberries as
they're about to come off of the vine
grapes
mulberries pick whatever it is that you
want
the shadow of Decay he says gives them A
peculiar beauty that being right on the
cusp not yet decaying but close to it
then he goes on and he says stalks of
wheat bending under their own weight
ripe full of the seed that we will then
take and grind and turn into flower and
we could say this about any other kind
of plant think about growing beans and
seeing the vines or peas right just
being born down by their own weight I
remember once having a peach tree that
had produced so many fruit that the I
actually had to make sure to pull them
off because it was at risk of breaking
the branches on the tree but then he
goes and says uh two other things that
are very interesting as examples here
lions and boars the furrowed brow of the
lion when the the Lion's brow is
furrowed it is upset it is a little bit
angry it's about to do lion stuff right
and get out there and attack that even
has I mean it's terrifying but it has
its own Beauty to it right we might say
the snarl on a dog's mouth even and then
he brings up the boar now boar are no
joke a wild boar are kind of
um
terrifying creatures flecks of foam on
The Boar's mouth right all of these
things many people would say they're not
beautiful they're actually kind of gross
kind of ugly kind of terrifying
Marcus is saying all of those have their
charm and attractiveness when we look at
them in the right way
so how should we look at that he tells
us well when we look at these things in
isolation
you know isolated from other things or
even interestingly there's kind of a
play on words here it could be when we
think about them abstractly in
accordance with their archetype their
idea right then they don't measure up
and we're not happy with them uh they're
far from beautiful poro is the word
they're distanced from being something
attractive
but when they're supplementing at Baku
luthane following upon
nature then they enrich nature they add
to it they they make it more real more
concrete and they attract us right again
this function of epigogon they draw Us
in they how is it translated in in this
one
um
it's uh
yeah draw us into the the aesthetic
experience
and so he tells us now here's where we
get to some of the criteria a person who
has feeling pathos usually pathos is a
bad thing but here Marcos Marcus is
using it in a good way when you have
feeling and a deeper sensitivity and
neuron bathut around so bathus is depth
right going down deep into the ocean
caves oneself
sensitivity here annoyance so the annoya
are common ideas that the stoics thought
that we all have as human beings but
some people are able to make better use
of them some people are able to access
them more easily so if we have a feeling
and deeper sensitivity for and it's
translated here as nature but really
the more literal translation would be
chords
those things that occur
in the totality right so nature works
but the emphasis here is on those things
and on them being part of a greater
whole perost
the the totality the whole the universe
right and tag ignoma the things that
come into being as we've talked about
before so the person who has this
will find pleasure and he uses the word
heideos he will find them pleasantly or
Pleasant right
um they will find pleasure in these
things and what does he give as examples
the jaws of live animals so Lions boars
dogs all these sorts of things he will
find the jaws of these live animals and
live there is translating it's a true
animals real animals as beautiful as
painted ones or sculptures this is a
very interesting observation some people
would say well we don't like you know
the scary monstrous animal over there
when we we actually have to see it but
we love it in a painting or we love it
in a sculpture then we can look at it at
our Leisure and we're not worried about
it eating us or biting us or hurting us
in some way but Marcus is saying even in
the live animals we can find beauty in
their jaws or
the distinct beauty of old age in men
and women
so typically we think about
aging as a process of losing Beauty
right because we equate Beauty with
youth Marcus is saying you can look at
any person and those lines on their face
are you know if we look at it in terms
of the greater whole and we actually pay
attention to what's going on there they
can be beautiful stretch marks can be
beautiful uh blemishes can be beautiful
having too many freckles can be
beautiful getting a sunburn can have a
certain kind of beauty to it as well he
also talks about children children have
their own you know little kinds of
beauty as well and we might extend this
to animals you know as they age or our
little children too and he says other
things like that this isn't a exclusive
or comprehensive list other things like
that will come to him constantly if he's
paying attention to the world right so
on these things are unnoticed by others
who are not adequately attending to them
or are judging them in relation to you
know some sort of Ideal that they don't
measure up to
when those people do that they're
depriving themselves of the opportunity
to experience this charm and
attractiveness to experience pleasure to
experience Beauty in these matters that
surround us constantly
he says
things seen only by those at home with
nature and its Works those who actually
can be at home with nature and its works
not preoccupied not distracted not
judging these works by the wrong
criteria
can actually have a much more enjoyable
experience of the Myriad things that are
part of their life and that surround
them and that could charm and even
Captivate them and give them pleasure in
a certain way